[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
825-5225 and i am rachel cruz hosting
this hour next to me is george camel
george let's make a good hour it is i
hope
you're saying a lot there very
aspirational no it's it is i'm gonna say
it as a fact so yeah we're here to talk
about anything about your life whether
it's your relationships your mental
health your money so just give us a call
so we're going to start out with
beau in dallas texas hey bo welcome to
the show
i appreciate it thanks for having me on
absolutely how can we help
so
i'm 23 i've been working a job for about
10 months out of college make good money
make about 78 000 a year in a couple
months i should be getting a raise
anywhere from 90 to 100. nice i've
always been pretty uh
pretty good saving my money for about
past five years i've got about 20 000 in
a fidelity account
15 000 in bitcoin which i know you guys
are going to you know give me the what
face about maybe not but and then about
5 000 in a company 401k with a match but
my question is i only have about three
thousand dollars in my checking account
and in the inflationary environment
we're in you know i'm losing my
purchasing power every day just keeping
the money in my checking account and you
know i'm 23 single don't really think i
need to save up for a house in this
crazy housing market should i be
concerned about having the slow amount
of cash in my checking account you know
if an emergency comes up i could just
you know sell some of my stock or some
my bitcoin so that's been my question
should i you know
uh keep my cash balance low and keep the
aggressive investing up or maybe you
know try and uh beef up that checking
account yeah i mean it's a great
question um you know i always answer
these questions that if i woke up in
your shoes and for me having liquid cash
just to get where there's no strings
attached there's no hoops i have to jump
through hurdles i have to get over that
i can just literally get it right now if
i needed it
it gives me a sense of peace and if
there's something that happens that you
have to have cash
having something just available that's
not tied up in investments or even
bitcoin
i really do recommend so that's kind of
our three to six months worth of
expenses um when we talk about baby step
three do you have any debt at all are
you completely debt-free
no i'm debt-free i was lucky enough i
didn't have to pay for college and
that'll be you know my only big expense
so yeah i'm debt-free very cool you're
doing an incredible job bo i mean the
questions you're asking at 23 is it's
impressive so guy if i were you yeah i
would i would have some money and you
can even start saving for it now if you
want um you know and just saying hey i'm
on baby step three and then start saving
for that fully funded emergency funds um
you could do that because if you if you
love this other stuff that you have your
money in but i would probably just cash
out
um one of those investments probably the
bitcoin i know you're not shocked that
i'm going to say it's not doing great
anyways bo let's be honest
yeah thank you but here's what i'm
thinking why can't you do both why not
have a fully funded emergency fund and
be investing so i think right now your
next goal should be to beef up your
savings uh leave that money in checking
and create a three to six months
expenses savings account and then you
can begin investing 15 beyond that start
saving up for a house is that your next
goal
yeah i think eventually that's the route
i want to go to my like my one thing
with that is i know you know investing
at a young age is so much more important
than investing later on and with you
know the market taking such a big hit
right now i think you know it's just
such a great opportunity to keep you
know in like uh really aggressively
investing at this age yeah and it is so
and i even love the framework that you
have when it comes to the market because
a lot of people are panicked and freaked
out and they don't want to put money in
when you're in a position that you're in
with no debts and you have you know soon
an emergency fund that's where the
perfect time to be investing
aggressively so yeah you're exactly on
the right track bo i don't think that
you're gonna
go wrong anywhere here i would i would
though have some money liquid
just in case something happens you're
able to get to it quickly to your
question bro you were saying that the
liquid cash scares you because it's not
beating inflation but the purpose of the
emergency fund is not to be an
investment it's insurance and so
insurance protects what you're trying to
build and so i'm totally okay with your
emergency fund not being invested and
just sitting in a boring savings account
making you one percent i'm totally good
with that because when an emergency hits
i don't want you dipping into your
investment accounts to cover that i want
you to cover that with your emergency
fund that's what it's there for so i
like keeping things neat and tidy and
separate so that way no one gets
confused here and to your question of
investing aggressively you're going to
be a multi-millionaire just based on the
numbers you told me if you don't
lifestyle creep enter your life as you
get this raise you keep living on less
than you make you invest i also know
there's other goals it's not all about
investing you have to live your life
you've got to go on vacations you're
going to want to upgrade the car you're
going to want to buy a house so balance
it a little bit i can tell with young
investors rachel which i love i know
they can they tend to get real tunnel
vision when it comes to investing and
that's all they think about well that's
a good point because and it's easy to
because you see the math and like what
he said he's like i know investing early
on is so much better because you see
compound interest so you see the math
you see the dollar signs in your eyes
you're like heck why would i do anything
else except for put money in because of
what it could do with compound interest
but you don't factor in life into the
equation and who knows bo you can meet a
girl tomorrow and you kind of fall in
love and you're going to want an
engagement ring you know what i'm saying
like anything can happen in life
and having money there uh is huge and
having it as part of your life strategy
knowing that yes while investing is
exciting and the earlier start the
better off you're going to be all of
that
but there's also life and with the
numbers you shared bo i'm seeing a lot
of what i assume is single stocks in the
fidelity account potentially uh and
bitcoin and a little bit in the 401k i
would flip flop that and lean into the
401k invest in good gross stock mutual
funds and then if you want to play with
some crypto or single stocks on the side
that's fine but i don't want it to be a
large portion of your net worth because
they are way more volatile than your
mutual funds yeah when your whole
retirement
uh if if all of your retirement is in
bitcoin which i know bose isn't but
that's that's not a great plan not a
great plan agreed all right george we've
been hitting the road recently yeah we
were in orlando last week yes and
they're there right now with our entree
summit event with 3 000 uh business
leaders
there and so we are we're it feels like
life is back and this fall it is like
it's game on it's so fun schedule has
hit and we are pumped to be back on the
road so if you can just imagine
the energy of a jam-packed arena with
people ready to experience what it means
to live life to the fullest so picture
all of your favorite speakers together
on one stage empowering you with
principles so that you can have
unstoppable momentum in your life and
that my friends is the smart conference
and we have not done it it feels like in
a few years we did it here in nashville
last year but
man we it's been three years that's
right yeah and so we are going to dallas
saturday october 22nd and this is our
biggest event of the year it's always
kind of the blowout event and you don't
want to miss it it's a day-long event
with the leading experts when it comes
to money personal growth leadership
mental health relationships and your
career you'll leave with all the
knowledge and motivation that you need
to have to reach your goals
and to live the life that you want and
so here
it's all of the ramsey personalities
will be on the stage
so dr john let me see if i can do them
well here we go dave ramsey yep dr john
celony ken coleman christina ellis
george campbell
rachel cruz nailed it eddie and eddie
and courtney will be hosting one of them
or they'll be around a plus
gold star and then our special guests
craig and amy grochelle from life church
are coming as well
to kind of round out that spiritual
element of our lives but all of it you
guys it is a fun fun event so make sure
to get your tickets they just start at
39 an amazing price for a full day event
so go to ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more this is the ramsay
show
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit
whether you do it yourself or you have
them measure and install everything for
you shop their latest looks and see how
much you can save at blinds.com today
the easy and affordable way to make your
home more beautiful is blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i am
rachel cruz co-hosting today with
ramsay personality george hamill all
right up next is tanner from north
carolina hey tanner welcome to the show
hi rachel and george
how are you doing
i'm doing great how are you we're doing
well how can we help
i had a quick question i'm currently 19
years old i drive a 300 000 mile vehicle
it runs fantastic and i have no problems
thus far with it
but um
i was wondering what is the age to stop
spending on once and start spending on
the future i always hear people say oh i
wish i'd started this or that
does that mean they started 22 or 25 or
19
my my real question is i'm looking to
when this vehicle dies
to maybe get a nicer vehicle obviously
pay cash for it um but i was thinking
something around the 30 thousand
dollar mark with uh get something cool
and fun like a muscle car
would this be a wise choice or should i
um perhaps get another six thousand
dollar vehicle it'll last for
another five or six years
and then uh invest that money in a down
payment or something like that yeah
great question tanner are you in school
right now are you working what's kind of
your status
i'm currently working um i do a side
hustle and i also have a main job okay
and how much do you make a year
um
approximately thirty thousand dollars
combined okay
so our rule of thumb just to answer the
car question and then george can jump
into the kind of the lifestyle question
but the the car we always say that you
don't want anything on wheels
to be half of your annual income
so if you were to go and save up for a
30 000 car
uh while you're making 30 000 that would
not be smart because that would mean
most of what you're making is
your net worth is in your car uh so if
you were still making 30 i would shoot
for a 15 000 car at the most but you can
still get a great car
for ten
twelve thousand dollars you know even
even below fifteen thousand so
um if you have the cash and you're able
to
uh pay for it in full that's kind of
where i would recommend do you have um
do you have any debt right now
i do not no does how much money do you
have in the bank
um so
i was a little unwise with spending um
so about three months ago i had probably
about a hundred dollars i've thus
tightened down in the last three months
i've accumulated eighty five hundred
dollars um you're working and just
really uh you must be saving every penny
man
yeah yeah definitely on big change wow
well to your original question you said
what's the proper age to stop spending
on wants and plan for the future
and the truth is you're always going to
be buying things that you want and you
should always be planning for the future
so i don't see them as mutually
exclusive i see them as things you
factor into your monthly budget so have
some things that you're looking forward
to some short-term goals but also be
investing for the future in a retirement
plan do you have any kind of plan
through your employer right now for that
there is a plan through my employer but
currently i'm not i'm signed up for that
okay
now i do want you to have a fully funded
emergency fund which may be that 8 500
you're sitting on which means we're not
going to touch it for the car we need to
set up a different savings account to
start saving up for that next car
yeah so i would probably honestly if i
were you tanner just because it has 300
000 miles on it which is awesome that
you've literally driven it to that point
but it's it's probably getting close to
its last leg there just from a mileage
perspective what kind of car is this i'm
just curious
it is a 2007 ford edge ford edge let's
go forward i was going to assume toyota
i was going to say a camry camry is
where i would put my money but i
toyota toyota i get made fun of for how
i say it what do you say i say toyota oh
it's toy sorry tanner i'm so sorry you
ought to hear that through the phone
that's a terrible pronounce way to go
forward making a car so yeah that's a
long time so tanner
i would do your emergency fund which
again george say could be that 8 500 and
then i probably would sit there and save
a little bit more cash because what i
don't want to happen is that that
wonderful ford with 300 000 miles
suddenly becomes undrivable and you're
like oh gosh and then you have to dip
into your emergency fund so i would
start saving on the side
for a car
um but i would only do that for maybe i
don't know what would you say george
maybe six seven months and then i would
start investing so i would kind of do
both at the same time but i would jump
start to that car fund
even before investing because of what
it's going to cost you yeah and i would
definitely try to get your income up
because you're working you said you have
a full-time job and a side hustle and
you're pulling in 30 000
what kind of job is
this i'm a
technician for uh i pull fiber
and data cables for uh installing things
such as printer jacks that you plug into
your printer
setting up server towers cool that kind
of stuff i would see what roles in that
industry you could step into grow into
even talk to your employer about what
growth looks like i mean you're 19.
you've got your whole life ahead of you
i've no doubt you're going to do great
but i think with that income it's going
to be harder to save up it's going to be
harder to invest harder to get a down
payment making 30 000 yeah so you're on
you're on the right track though tana
you're doing doing an awesome job all
right up next is tyler from boston hey
tyler welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing appreciate you
taking my call absolutely how can we
help
so i'm currently in baby step two um
however i was just contacted by my
landlord who i've been breaking for the
last couple of years and basically told
me he's gonna be selling the condo that
i'm living in and present me with two
options option one is assault to a real
estate investor who will keep me onto
the tenant however he's gonna bring rent
up to what you know some more units are
getting i'm currently paying you know a
pretty decent deal paying less
option two would be he would sell it to
me for about five to ten grand under
market value
um so i'm just kind of curious what you
guys would suggest this you know being
in baby step two i know you typically
advise you know waiting to look for
download to get a down payment but being
filled up market under market value and
the mortgage payment coming about to be
the same as the rent would be what you
guys would recommend here
yeah it's a great question and it's and
i understand from the math perspective
it seems like it would be a wash it's
like well if i'm paying rent might as
well be paying mortgage but you don't
factor in everything else
that goes into owning you know even if
it's a condo townhome house
everything else so so even though it
seems like a great deal right now even
though he's going to give you a little
bit less it's
in the long run tyler i don't think it's
a smart i don't think it's a smart move
for where you're at you have no cash in
the bank you don't have an emergency
fund you still have debt
all of it just kind of seems like
a setup for disaster and we always say
when you want to own something like real
estate your home we want it to be a
blessing not a curse and
setting yourself up in this particular
situation i think would be would be hard
um so i would not i would not go forward
with it yeah tyler how much debt do you
have
so i found you guys about five months
ago started with 116 000 of student
loans car and got that down um to about
70 thousand now nice tyler great job
what's your income
uh well i've recently just switched jobs
and got my income from 85 000 to 120
000. heck yeah amazing that's fantastic
so this debt is going to be gone within
what year and a half or so
yep my spreadsheet has you about a year
and a half to maybe just shy to
depending on you know how some expenses
go fantastic well i want you to be a
homeowner i just don't want this home to
have you and i know it's it's a slight
deal but we don't know what the market's
going to do it could it could even out
and i want you to get a home when the
time is right when it's going to be a
blessing in your life and not a curse
and right now when you're sitting on
seventy thousand dollars in debt with
those payments you have no down payment
you have no emergency fund that's a
scary place to be
and there's something too about you know
obviously tyler probably loves the condo
he's in or he wouldn't be there to an
extent
but also when you own a home it's like
you want to be able for it to be exactly
what you want i mean i know it's not
going to be the perfect situation for
you know we're not no one's ever going
to get exactly what they want but
if it's kind of like oh i just happen to
be in here and i happen could to be able
to buy it sometimes that works out but
also you never know what you know you
could be in a different area and get you
know an even better condo
for less i mean you could just you have
more options when you have options but
when you're stuck in time this is the
only decision yeah sometimes you don't
always make the best decision
um and that urgency is there too so i
totally get that tyler of like oh man
this would be so nice we could just do
this and i would have to move my rent
won't go up all of it but if i were you
yeah i think in the long run um it's
gonna be better just have the patience
and save up and pay for something later
on down the road i feel for those people
who want to be homeowners right now and
it's just just so it's terrible y'all
it's terrible oh it's so frustrating we
acknowledge that yeah absolutely and the
hard thing is too though that like you
know we say it around here but it's true
we're not exempt from math and there's
still a formula to be said when it comes
to being wise about making one of the
largest purchases you'll ever make in
your lifetime when it comes to real
estate
and it's not something you want to rush
into you want to make sure you have
solid financial foundation under you
even if that means even if that means
it's gonna take time the patience is
worth it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show so on
friday of this past week george and i
hosted and we had a call
and it ended up being kind of a
memorable one not necessarily because of
the call but more so because of um
i'm gonna say george's reaction maybe my
reaction played into it your reaction to
my reaction
that's what it was so so if you
you want me to recap it for him yeah
yeah here's what happened america uh
katie called in from kentucky in a rural
area there and she had 34 makes 34 000 a
year had a side hustle where she would
do horseback riding on one of her horses
for about 300 bucks a month horace gets
injured that depletes her side hustle
money that was coming in so now she's
asking us for what side hustle options
she has at the end of the call i ask how
much debt she has turns out she has 118
dollars in debt making thirty four
thousand and that's when i realized this
is a very
bad situation this is not a well yeah
side hustle your way out with she was
making a hundred bucks a month selling
quilts on etsy and in my head i'm going
this is not going to cut it we need to
do better so at the end of the call i
said hey kd i want to challenge you
could you sell the horse
and the reaction from rachel from
the lobby that was not the reaction the
reaction was hey would you sell the
horse and katie says no and george says
it doesn't even know your name katie
which i do regret i said it in a moment
of passion because i want to help katie
win financially
and as much as i love animals i'm not an
animal hater i never said shoot the
horse
there's another family that could have
the horse and here's what here's what
happened katie emailed us yes with
photos of her riding said horse we have
the photos to show you if you're
watching on youtube it's very impressive
an amazing horse so can i you want to
read part of her email yes so she emails
after the show
and says my name is katie and i live in
kentucky i called earlier this afternoon
and was fortunate to have my call on the
ramsey show
i feel like i caused a large debate over
selling the horse or not so i wanted to
follow up my first name
is 16 years old and as a barrel horse
i've owned them for 11 years
he is a top performance horse worth
twenty thousand dollars in today's
market moose moose and i have traveled
the entire midwest together and have
shown
and won too many things to list
we have been through surgeries and fear
all the way to happiness
together she went on to say yes horses
are expensive however i sacrifice
multiple things in order to be able to
afford to have him and show him yes you
have katie
my plan is to heavily focus on growing
my sewing business while my horse is on
stall rest yes the vet bills will be
covered without going into debt thank
you emergency fund good for you katie
she's in fpu she's working through baby
step two she can't wait to be debt free
and come do her scream on the show
without selling her twenty thousand
dollar horse she adds i love the show
and i've learned a vast amount about
finance hope you all enjoy reading this
email thank you so much katie and moose
the horse
so
it is sun katy and me so appreciate the
photos i there's a lot of things i
learned after this email and you know
what i may have a different take now
that i've really processed it wow have
you changed your mind i've not changed
my mind i think
moose is just going to be a very
expensive pet
in her life but i think she needs to
quit everything
that she's doing and go get another
full-time
job that has nothing to do with quilts
has nothing to do with horses
and then get two
part-time jobs
after the full-time job i think she just
needs to shift careers i agree which it
sounded like she was working at the usda
and she had just shifted out of her vet
technologist kind of role and so i think
at that point wanna shift again and she
lives in a rural area so not a lot of
jobs obviously she can't up and move
because the horse has her tied down stop
it she can move she can't no she's got
the horse
how do you move with a horse you got to
find an area at the farm no i'm not a
horse i don't have a stable i'm not a
horse here's my here's my thing i'm not
i should have i should have googled more
about having a horse before we brought
the segment back you know this horse
people are passionate people
they love horses more than life itself
and i applaud them for crossfitters
vegans
horse people are willing to sacrifice
just about everything to have this horse
yeah and that's what hurt my heart was i
want okay
i want katie to win financially yes and
i just was going she's going to be in
debt for the rest of her life at this
point because these side hustles aren't
panning out and so to her credit we did
not give her enough side hustle options
that she could do in her area because i
don't live in a rural part of kentucky
but i did look up her city in kentucky
on indeed and there are many many
part-time jobs that pay over twenty
dollars an hour ah well done so my
challenge to katie's to jump on indeed
or whatever job search site you want to
go to and go find a better part-time job
i don't think right now is the time to
jump into passion projects
that is the truth yes and
i don't even know if i want to say this
say it but don't let an animal hold you
back
to winning financially there we go
that's a much nicer way to put it is
that a fair thing to say very diplomatic
the way i said it was not
no
but if you can find a way to still keep
the horse because i've
i've heard other hosts on the show talk
about like hey if you have a
you know a a classic car that you built
with your dad
30 years ago like
you you can keep that you don't have to
sell like there's certain things you
don't have sentimental value yes even
dave would say all right fine yeah he
said hey keep the gun it's sentimental
you want to pass it down to your kid
keep whatever right because it has a lot
of sentimental value yeah so the horse
could be that right agreed she's not
going to sell the horse she's made that
clear yes
my job is to find out what people are
willing to do to get out of debt and so
i was just poking to go would you be
willing just honestly i poked the bear i
poked the horse really i feel good and
uh wow got a hoof in my face from
everyone on the internet some people are
like i'm never listening to this guy
again were they pro there were a few
people that are pro they're team george
who said yeah she needs to sell the
horse yeah yeah it's worth twenty
thousand dollars it's worth more than
katie herself
think about that
i'm just saying on a net worth level oh
the horse is an adult oh in a net worth
level on a net worth level no human life
over everything
i don't know guys this is my last day on
air you i was trying to do a nice thing
yourself
rachel i don't count on one finger how
many times someone's apologized on the
show and it's me i apologize to katie
for saying that the horse doesn't know
her name someone sent me a video of a
horse knowing someone's name
thousand dollars maybe not on paper
katie because technically your net worth
yes is in the negative but who she is
is one more than more really guys this
would have sounded like george
that's what that's what it sounded like
this don't be triggered by me listen
it's not worth it okay we all know i was
not saying that i love katie i want her
to win i can't wait for her to do her
debt-free scream and find out what side
hustles she picked up yeah what happened
with the horse is is the horse gonna be
okay i hope so after the surgeries
and the other horse she had two horses
by the way by the way the other one was
adopted
and it's a it's a younger horse
so i apologize to moose as well yeah i'm
gonna say look in that camera george
moose
i don't know what cameron moose i love
you i'm pulling for you buddy hope you
get well soon get back on the track and
get katie's side hustle alive again
thank you katie so speaking of side
hustles what were some of the things you
found because in a in a metropolitan
area
side hustles are everywhere whether it's
driving
for you know
delivery or
uber or whatever so if you are you know
within 25 miles 17 plus an hour throw
out some options because other people
might be listening that are thinking
high school degree
accounting associate
nice there's one sales representative
and they a lot of these people provide
training that and it's remote work so
even if you are in a rural area
you can still plan
jobs a lot of remote jobs that are
happening so even if you are somewhere
that you're not near a big city
you can still have a great income yes by
doing a lot of this remote work and so
that's always my question when someone
says hey i've got a side hustle i make
xyz and sell it on etsy and they're
making 100 bucks i go well you can make
more than that in four hours working at
the walmart down the road which there is
a walmart in our town
they're probably hiring they probably
pay 17 18 bucks an hour these days yeah
so why not do that for a shift after
your full-time job yes and make 500
bucks a month because also this is the
time if you're listening you know just
using her as an example but when you are
in debt and you you know
you're don't have an emergency fund
you're kind of in this situation
the time when it comes to your job and
how you make money it's not going to be
your heart your soul your passion your
life calling
you're gonna just do what you can to
bring in the most money as possible
during that period and then once you
don't have debt you have a savings
account you're like okay i can like i
have options i have options but for now
the goal is not going after what your
heart desires it really is like hey
what can i do to make the most money to
get out of debt as quickly as possible
good talk
george i'm done with horse content
we're leaving we are leaving
okay this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five all right up next is linda
from san antonio hey linda welcome to
the show hi there
i'm kind of excited to talk to you all
i've listened to your dad for years
so great linda i'm glad you called how
can we help
well you know i gave the screener some
information i am an everyday millionaire
but nice linda awesome congratulations
yes um
my husband and i worked really hard for
it uh and he's he's gone now he's
i've been a widow about six years but he
had me set up pretty well so
the issue i have you had somebody on who
was still working and this is a great
time to be investing okay i have about
four hundred thousand in a in various
things an ira and roth and a brokerage
account
and then i because of where we worked
the
you know
i also have about a 650 um annuity
that's not annuitized it was part of my
husband and my retirement from where we
were working i don't have to everyone
limitize it and i don't intend to when i
see my i'm getting more waffles from the
other stuff i think
but i kind of wonder if i should be
investing
right now
or
just sitting this out because i am 73 so
you know i i don't know how long i'm
gonna live i could live you know a long
time
and you do have to be exposed if you're
you know
a little bit
sure no absolutely
so so linda tell me what what other
money do you have because if you are an
everyday millionaire is most of it is
some of that in your
home do you have a paid off house do you
have other accounts
last year i sold my residence i had a
condo and also had a rental property and
i sold them both and ended up buying uh
i was in a two-story condo and i wanted
a one-story with a yard so i did that
and you know got a good price for the
condos but then i had to pay a bigger
price than i wanted for this house so i
have it's like 58 000 mortgage and
oh it's 276 a month and i have a
financial planner and she doesn't think
i should pay it off and of course i
haven't had a mortgage in a long time so
i've thought about paying it off
i have about forty thousand an emergency
fund and my checking accounts i guess i
have about fifty thousand between the
two of them
and i have
about 48 000 a year income from
retirement and then i've you know i
spend about 70.
you spend 70.
yeah the rest of it's from the
investments oh okay it throws off cash
so you know
all right and you're and you're
completely retired
uh-huh okay yeah wonderful actually
wonderful i would be driving around
pizzas or something
you're doing great
you're doing great so linda the four
hundred thousand dollars that's
currently invested
yes
uh the brokerage is actually in dividend
producing stocks and the other
the ira and the traditional ira and the
roths are in
mutual funds different mutual funds
which
are producing quite a well and each one
of those has a significant amount of
cash because
last year
i sold a lot of things and there was
nothing to buy
so there is a submit you know there's in
all three of those accounts there's a
fair amount of cash
well you're asking should you how should
you be investing because it sounds like
this money's already invested what money
are you looking to invest should i be in
that should i be buying things now with
some of the cash value that i have on
those various accounts or
yeah sitting on the cash side i would
definitely be investing that
okay and i would stay i would stay
aggressive i know that's a hot take in
the financial planning world rachel uh
with asset allocation theory basically
being well linda 73 we need to put her
in the most conservative bonds possible
so that she doesn't lose money but what
happens is linda's gonna live another 20
years and that account's going to get
depleted right that's kind of what i'm
afraid of
so we like to stick to the same strategy
with growth stock mutual funds and yes
there's going to be some volatility but
we found and statistics will back this
up that you'll end up doing better
having uh invested a little more
aggressively than if you left it real
conservative even even at your age linda
so yep that's that's it so well done
though i mean what an incredible job
yeah and i'd get that mortgage paid off
i'm not your financial planner but you
might need to fire them the fact that
that's their uh advice linda i really
would look at you know that we have
smart investor pros we actually just met
three out in the lobby yeah awesome from
all over the country and i would i would
i would look for somebody else that has
the idea of hey we want you to be able
to have no debt and be investing in
something even aggressive even a little
bit more aggressively than just standard
traditional bonds uh that some financial
planners will put you in but i like
where you're at where you're sitting
you're pretty well diversified and um
that's great so thanks linda thanks so
much for the call
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer for
custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promo codes they run every month you'll
save even more use promo code ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from amai in new jersey my husband and i
have paid off our credit card debt and
have 31 000 in car loans left to pay off
i'm thinking about selling my dream car
in order to be debt free i owe 17 000
and the car is worth 30 000
we have two other vehicles a beater that
my husband can continue to drive and a
2014 f-150 that i would drive i think i
could sell my car for about 27 000 and
use the 10 000 profit towards the 14 000
truck loan we're currently renting and
this step could get us closer to buying
a home please tell us if this is a good
idea as this is a very emotional
decision for me
oh man it's a lot of numbers so 31 000
and carlin left to pay off she could get
10k profit she sold the car
so she'd be down yeah to 21. so i'm
seeing here they have three cars
currently yes and one
truck has a 14k loan the dream car has a
17k loan but that 17k loan she could
sell that same car for 27 to 30 000.
making a nice profit right now so i'm a
big for sure yes
now the emotion i think is coming out of
this is my dream car anyone anytime i
see the word dream i think wow it's the
only one in existence the only one ever
that will ever be built in the history
of this world whether it's a car or a
home yeah the dream
that word it
it holds a lot of emotion and sometimes
not the wisest financial decision that's
true because of what we believe in that
it becomes very singular focus that this
is it and you can make really bad
decisions never be able to buy this car
again never it's true george so
well it's not true rachel i was i was
being sarcastic so yes am i i would sell
that dream car i would use the profit
towards the 14k loan you're spot on
because this is gonna cut your your
debt-free journey in half
yeah
so oh gosh so fast so fast so you're
trading one sacrifice for another and
you got three cars so you're gonna be
okay
it is amazing though when when you go on
this journey to change your mindset
around money because what am i in is a
very normal situation right thirty one
thousand dollars in car loans uh they
had a credit card debt that they've
already paid off but i'm like it's
that lifestyle the credit card debt the
car alone even throwing a student loan
just for fun
that is the normal mindset in america
today when it comes to money and so
shifting that
mindset flipping it on its head and say
okay what if it looked like if i didn't
use credit cards and i paid off my debt
what if i actually drove a car that i
could pay cash for
which may mean me selling my current car
you know or aggressively paying it off
you know it
makes the whole decisions when it comes
to money
it changes everything it changes the way
you look at this stuff and part of that
is
selling
things to be able to get you ahead and
thinking about opportunity cost if i
drive my dream car it means we can't be
in that house that we want to buy which
she mentioned for another five years but
if we sold the car we got a debt faster
we could start saving up for the down
payment faster we could get in that
house in three years and so then you
start to go what's more important to me
what do i value more
looking fancy in a depreciating asset or
being in a home because we've been
renting for our whole life yep and we
want to be at home you make different
decisions when you look at yeah through
that lens that and that's the importance
too of having long-term and short-term
goals though to say hey what do we want
to do because if if if you weren't
thinking about buying a house then you'd
probably just be doing what you've been
doing today but for for am i it's like
okay i could what i want in the future
here in the next few years i can make
sacrifices today to get what i really
want that actually would be a smart
decision financially that dream it
always changes three years from now
you'll have a different dream absolutely
just wait a second absolutely well we
want to thank austin kelly will zach and
andrew in the booth thank you george
for sitting with me co-hosting at this
hour and thank you america for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am
rachel cruz and joining me this hour is
ramsey personality george camel and we
are taking your calls
about anything in life whether it comes
to your career your money your
relationships so just give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five it's a free call
anywhere in the country all right first
up is sierra from portland oregon hey
sierra welcome to the show
hi rachel thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help
um well i just became a new mom about 10
and a half months ago congratulations
thank you so much
my son was born
prematurely
and we had to spend some extended time
in the nicu
and before that i was running a very
successful business and it was about a
six-figure business
and because he came so early and we
didn't have a plan in place um and i
never left the nicu my business has kind
of crumbled and
as a new mom i didn't
i did i'm sure a lot of people laugh at
this but i didn't expect it to be as
much work as i
thought it would be and i am not willing
to sacrifice putting my child in daycare
and losing this
this precious time because we had
infertility issues and this may be my
only chance to experience this so that
value was really high to me
but our income has dropped significantly
um probably in half
and i'm wondering how do i balance
work
uh establishing a business back up and
also
watching my child while
i am married and my spouse works
full-time as an apprentice
so um he's out two nights a week for
school and um
i just i guess we're kind of we did the
budget
and our mortgage is about 40 of our
budget right now and
um all of our debts will be paid off and
we'll only have a mortgage by september
of this year okay
so how much were you guys making when
the business was at its peak and then
what are you guys making now
about 150
before taxes and then now we're making
about i'd say 89k before taxes okay
so about 90.
and you guys with that 90 is when you
think you'll be completely debt free by
september
yeah we already have a plan in place i
just have to contribute money to my my
retirement my stop ira for okay
my business
okay and did your business was it just
you solo doing it or what did you have
team members that had to be let go when
it crumbled what was kind of the history
we let someone go when covet happened
and that's
kind of we had counted on doing
something
to replace that person when the baby
came but
yeah life just kind of changed yeah for
sure so what kind of business is it
um i do personalize drinkware and hd
wedding signs but that code kind of took
that away yes the wedding market well
it's back it's i feel like it's yeah
exactly yeah i know it's like the
perfect time to rebound but yeah time
has been hard and we also do i should
say we have
um we will have already three months of
savings um
saved up we've
been really good with money and we have
been paying extra on our mortgage so far
but now we're kind of like oh what do we
do how do we allocate money like what if
the economy crashes
sure sure
well you guys got a lot of things going
on so here's what i would say
in fact no no no it's not a bad thing at
all um
so when it comes to the financial part
of this conversation you know you guys
are still contributing to retirement you
have an emergency like you kind of have
everything before baby step two and we
talk about baby step two is putting
everything to get out of debt but with
these numbers if you guys are gonna be
out of debt in september
um you know that's currently when you're
calling i mean that's that's going to be
in about three four months so
i'm not overly concerned um
with what you guys have george may may
push back a little bit on that i don't
know yeah i'm just wondering what the
timeline would look like if you didn't
invest right now if you took everything
in savings but the one thousand dollars
and threw it all to debt could you be
debt free by next month
so i have to contribute the money
because i
stated i would contribute the money with
our tax return so i always usually end
when they're like so you essentially
pledged this money and the irs is like
hey you said you were going to invest
this
yeah and i do have the money the way my
business which is i'm doing more
wholesale orders and they have met 30
through the platform i sell on just to
get to pay so my money's being held
which i know your dad would have a cow
over this rachel but
it's just the way that i'm kind of set
up so i'm looking to work towards
diversifying more towards another
platform that i was on that was really
lucrative so okay so is the business
currently making money
yeah so so far this year i have done
about i would say 30k um in revenue but
my problem too is like supplies have
doubled the cost like not doubled but
they've increased dramatically and my
profit margins are so much smaller so
have you raised your money
i have i just recently um did that and
i've cut my pay down to just a thousand
dollars a month so that i can make sure
i'm buying supplies okay
so are you wanting to continue doing
this business from home while caring for
your son
yes what is that the end goal like you
don't want to just be full-time
watching your son and you can't be
full-time in the business you want to
kind of split your time a little bit
yes that's correct and i think it'll get
easier my husband turns out as
apprentice he'll be done it'll be a
journeyman um next year
june 2023 so um yeah so it feels like a
year from now your life looks very
different and you can start to rebuild
the business while you're caring for
your son at home while your husband
increases income and finishes the
apprenticeship and so this feels like a
temporary problem
yeah because we have been listening to
y'all for a while now and we're like
should we sell our house it takes up too
much of our budget like we're living
outside of our means well it sounds like
with this business that you have going
if you can keep this up you'll have that
mortgage payment be a lot less than 40
percent
yeah i think that if i went back on
track and i had
some time um
and someone to watch my son but i don't
i mean my parents all all of our family
was too far away so
yeah so what i would say is sierra you
may not let you know it may not go back
to what it was because you're not going
to have the time you had obviously
before and if since you're wanting to be
so hands-on with your summary which i
think it's amazing and i think that
that's a life value that's going to
drive a lot of your other decisions
that's actually a great one um
then you guys need to make a realistic
plan and a realistic goal of okay hey i
was making six figures out of this
business it's really i'm gonna shoot to
make fifty thousand this this year or
sixty thousand whatever you think is
realistic um of figuring out what you
can do that feels balanced for you at
home and then from those numbers figure
out if the house is too much because if
it goes down you know to 28 at that
point then you might be okay but if it's
still hovering around 35 then yeah you
probably you guys probably do have a lot
of house and you can make
progress so much faster a lot
of equity in our home and when he turns
out we could sell our house and move to
a different state and pay cash for a
house and be completely debt free yes
and that's something
that we've talked about yeah so it's
options like that sarah definitely that
i would look at and to know that you
know
uh you're gonna you're gonna be spending
a lot of time with that baby which i
think is amazing but it is going to make
your work the time is going to be a
little bit less which is totally fine
but i think you guys are on the right
track i think your values are exactly
where they need to be and you guys are
just making great decisions so thanks
for the call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
me
[Music]
still on baby step number one how'd you
guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget don't
worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i am
rachel cruz co-hosting today with george
campbell and up next is mary from des
moines hey mary welcome to the show
oh my gosh is this real life rachel
george hello alternate reality you're in
the metaverse welcome
i am very excited this is the second
best day of my life
what was the first
my wedding oh
this is my third best day
that's awesome
so great how can we help
okay well my husband is in his
uh the end of his residency
and right now he's making 62k
and then he just got a new job and so
it's going to put him at 200k oh wow
yeah and then so we get
it is very
blessing and nice yes
and he also is being offered a 75k
sign-on bonus
um
so
as i would love a horse or a dream car
i would love to be out of debt more
love it good good good good mary we are
on the right track
you know what i'm saying
don't put the horse before the car
thank you that's what i'm saying
so we um my question is should we buy or
rent we're moving to another state
and then should we put the 75 000
towards student loans because we do have
that's our debt right now is 134
000 in student loans okay yeah
is that all of your debt
that is all of our debt
okay
all right mary
if i woke up in your shoes i love that
line because it just really what would
you do yeah
so um i would definitely rent for
multiple reasons one you guys still have
the student loan hanging over your head
number two you're moving to a new area
and planning routes down where you're
not 100 sure exactly maybe where you
want to be in the city
logistically i don't think it's smart so
i would rent regardless of even if you
had this debt or not i would still
recommend renting just to kind of get
your feet wet and understand okay here's
where we want to be what part of town we
want to be in
all that so
um i would still live mary like you guys
are in residency i would still live like
you are making 62 a year
and i would throw all of your income the
75
everything i would throw everything
at this debt because if you guys still
lived like you were making 60 you guys
could have this paid off
uh you know in in in 18 months 14 months
and it's crazy to think because
yes it's a lot of debts you know 134 000
but you guys have a huge shovel
with this 275 thousand dollars so it's
it's an incredible
um opportunity to to be able to get out
of that well you've got a debt in a year
that's i'm doing math here you have 59
left if you throw the 75 at the 134 it
leaves you with 59 in student loans
making 200. so let's say you net out 130
140 after taxes and you lived on a net
of 40 50.
this debt's gone within seven eight
months
okay
okay so
okay we have four little kids
so what should you said live like
no one else you can live like no one
else yeah yes so
just live
on the least amount possible and then
how have you guys been living
how have you guys been living on the 62
okay so we use every dollar
yes and true confession is we have
meetings every week or month and then
it's like oh we went over for whatever
reason this happened this happened so
we don't use the cash system which may
be something we we should be doing
because we use the every dollar and
we're like oh this is the same but it's
not because
i'm sure we're not doing it but we're
trying but you know yep yep oh
absolutely
so the budget yeah but have you guys
gone into debt for lifestyle or you've
lived at 62 000
we have lived at that yeah
okay so yeah so so the point is you can
do that for another year you guys and
it's not fun it's gonna be miserable
knowing golly he's gone through
residency all of us and we're getting
these kids you make so much money why
aren't we feeling it yet yes so it's so
i really would though i i have it yeah
yeah and i would marry i would still
just in your mindset and it is a mental
decision to say okay
i'm gonna we are still gonna live the
exact same lifestyle we've been living
for one more year for one more year and
that's it i mean you guys could be
completely debt free and then think
about this morning when you have no debt
and you have 275 000
coming in throughout the year that's all
yours you guys are gonna be able to
build up
an emergency fund so quickly you're
going to be able to have so much margin
so much breathing room but if you don't
go ahead and just make this intense move
of this idea of hey we're going to pay
all of this off so quickly
man it could it could hang and drag
and drag and then he's gonna you're
gonna get a great paycheck and it's
still gonna be going out to student
loans so
make this
this line in the sand you guys together
and do every dollar and really stick to
it and so um i want you to hold on the
line because i'm going to give you ship
you guys a rachel cruz wallet
because in that
amazing is the envelope system and so so
cash out your groceries cash out your id
look at the places that you guys tend to
overspend
and buckle down and and kind of go from
a clean slate because i think with
budgeting it can be defeating because
you feel like gosh you know we tried we
tried it just isn't working so you do
you have to have this new mindset of hey
this is the just pretend it's like your
first time and give yourself three
months
to really get more in the habit and i
promise the more intentional you are
with it and the more boundaries you set
and the more realistic your budget is
because your budget may not have been
realistic to your lifestyle 200 bucks
for food for six people yeah i didn't
know that wasn't going to be enough
that's right whatever it is but there is
a point to that rachel of when you're
doing a budget you have to look at the
budget before you spend a lot of people
just go spend and they look at the
budget and go up i went over how did
that happen well did you look to see how
much money you had left in your grocery
budget
and so when you do it that way that
helps a lot how much money do we have
left you know we didn't allocate enough
let's increase it let's move some things
over here in this category let's cut a
subscription to create that margin and
next month we're going to do better
and if you do that you will win with
money over time yeah and mary you guys
are in such a great position you've done
the hard work you know what it feels
like to live at 64 000 with four or five
kids like you know that you have
and you guys can keep doing it just keep
on that cut it cut it cut it and man you
guys could be debt free so quickly it's
amazing all right up next is shawn from
chicago hey sean welcome to the show
how hi how are you guys doing well how
can we help
yeah so this is a this is a pretty uh
cool question but it's kind of complex
so
i currently am working as an accountant
and
i actually found another job at another
position with a at a worldwide company i
thought this was good for
new opportunities and also i was
actually currently in a toxic
environment with my manager
but as i actually applied and accepted a
new offer i was counter offered at my
current position and this is kind of
appealing to me because this is actually
a promotion this is a new
um position this is a step up to where i
am right now it also will mean i have a
new manager so maybe the toxicity might
go down he also assured that i will be
in better hands now rather than the two
years that have already been here um and
i will also have a ten thousand dollar
increase in my salary so
um the new position at
the bigger company it's actually kind of
a step down i wanted a new opportunity
um as soon as possible i found this
position to step down to where i am
right now i would be
making less
i'll be making the i wouldn't be making
the same amount that i currently do
so i uh would be making this wow that i
currently do but i would be not making
that 10 grand if i were to go to the new
position
so i'm kind of i'm a young i'm young i'm
23 right now and i'm kind of just trying
to figure out so yeah so what's your
what's your question
yeah which one do you take trying to
figure out yeah which one to take is it
necessarily a bad thing if i
took the counteroffer i mean you trust
the leadership of the company you're
currently at
do you like it there other than that one
bad manager
other than that i do i do get along with
everybody here they get along with me
and that's why the connor offered me and
i do like it here i would want to get
that new position that new title on my
resume and that 10 000 bonus would be
nice as well so sean
deal man i think the answer is kind of
easy
i'm sticking with this company taking
the pay raise taking the new position
what's making you hesitant what makes
you want to go down in position and keep
the same
income at a different company well i've
heard bad things about taking a
counteroffer you know like down the line
you're gonna you're gonna get out of it
within uh six months
you're 23 man if it doesn't work out a
year from now you can still go find
another job you got lots of options out
there in the world but this sounds like
a great one they want to keep you so
they're showing you the money and giving
you a show me the money
yeah it's awesome sean i'd stay take the
new position and if it's still terrible
then you can leave in six months this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
825-5225 and up next is
ashley from charlotte north carolina hey
ashley welcome to the show
hey how are you guys today doing great
how can we help
awesome
so it's kind of an in-depth situation
but i'm going to try to cut to the chase
and if i'm too long-winded just you know
cut me off um
but
the short of it is that i am a business
owner in north carolina and
i've been a business owner for going on
six years and have been debt-free in
business up until this past year until
2021.
in 2020 we actually had the highest year
we've ever had
with gross revenues almost at a million
dollars
and we thought you know
me and my husband we
we don't have a business background we
kind of just fell into this and then
took advice um from my dad who's awesome
at finances and you know remained
debt-free but in 2021 we decided you
know we really need to get a handle
on how to buy inventory properly
and um
and also how to do marketing properly so
we got with the company not y'alls i
went to clarify that i was asked that
before the call not not anybody
affiliated with the ramsey
program
but
basically it ended us in a lot of debt
um
we have about 89 500 in debt and
at the end of it we parted ways but um
the ending call
was that basically they overbought us
and it was uh they caused us to overbuy
and i knew in my heart along the way
that this is
i felt like i wasn't doing the right
thing but they had over like 35 years of
experience right and um
a
advisory type
business that's that was helping you
look at your business plan and they are
kind of saying hey you need to be having
this business go into debt for all this
inventory it'll be great yeah
i guarantee exactly oh yeah i'm so sorry
shoot yeah okay so you made the decision
so you paid the stupid tax that's what
we always called around here when you do
something yes
and i would never do that again um i
literally had up until that point we had
been debt-free in our business and to me
that was like amazing we almost sold a
million dollars and
you know we did it without debt and um i
did it based on spreadsheets like two
plus two is four math right you know and
so um
i'm at the point you know where in
november of 2021
we just had to stop the bleeding and um
sorry i'm getting them to know but it's
okay it's hard we had to let go of our
staff
we did this because we didn't know what
to do and we were scared that we
couldn't pay them you know and we did we
couldn't keep going into debt
so
we made some really hard decisions but
now uh my husband got a job which he
actually loves and is doing great and we
still have the business but we're trying
to get back on the other side of this
you know basically have a real cash flow
a real cash system of everything yeah um
and so my question is i guess twofold
number one is we have a house that's um
worth about 390 000
um it could go for higher because people
we we don't have a lot of stock in our
area so who knows but i'm really
comfortable saying it would go for it
could go for 390. um we owe 238 on it
so besides the business debt in our
house that's the only that we have
and then the second one is am i dumb for
holding on to this business
easy one first ashley you're not dumb no
for holding on to the business or
otherwise
this is okay you're going to get through
this you're not dumb ashley now were
there decisions that you're like man i
hate that i did that yes yes but no so
for the past eight months oh actually
and you want to keep running this
business right stop beating yourself up
ashley okay the decision was made and
you and you you know you made the
decision and you regret it but i don't
want you i don't that's the thing about
money mistakes is there's they can be so
shameful and there's this inner critic
in your ear being like oh my gosh you're
in your head saying why did you do this
why did you do this why did you do that
so so listen you got it you got to shut
that down okay
stop stop thinking that okay and say hey
today's a new day and going forward and
making different decisions i hate that i
did that but hey so i'm going to be
doing i'm going to be making different
decisions so don't let that tape keep
playing in your mind sorry george no
it's all good so you want to keep
running this business correct
um
i feel to be honest i feel very tainted
from it like i feel very scarred um so
to speak but every day
even though i feel scarred i keep waking
up and doing it and i'm like why do i
keep doing it you know at this point i'm
in my head it's like mixed emotions i do
love it i love the people um so what
kind of business is it
so
which i'm glad that you guys uh rachel
and george because
you guys are the like uh what do you
call it the door dashers like um dave
desert light door dash and stuff like
that
but i've never heard him i think he does
but why okay so what is it then we are a
retail business so that's another
aspect of it is i own a woman's clothing
store
and we are online primarily right now
because we shut down our storefront uh
due to the pandemic
but we are getting to the point where we
do think opening this door back up would
bring another cash flow point in
and doing it the right way not going
into debt for it or anything like that
um but you know having
money in the bank and opening it back up
to have not only our online up and
running but also in store okay so when
you say that you're hard towards the
business is it more because of the
decisions you've made in the business or
the business itself
like if you had no if you had no debt on
it would you still want to be doing it
yes okay yeah okay so i would say it's
still it's still in your heart so how
much have you guys made
for instance this year
total household income
total household income yeah what do you
think you'll do this year
like for the business is everything
because your husband's working now at a
different job so what do you think
you'll bring in gross
as a household i think gross i think um
380 including the business okay so to me
this debt is going to be gone in a few
months
right
it's hard because we have other expenses
in the business
so i guess it's kind of we're kind of
conflicted like my husband now has taken
the um like he worked for the business
as well
so he has taken like all of our
household expenses is how i look at it
in my mind all of our business all of
our finances are combined so i don't
want you also think that but so he is
taking that aspect and my job basically
is to
in the business just make the money in
order to pay down the debt
does that make sense yeah no absolutely
okay so how much would the business make
then how much are you expecting to make
this year
i'm looking at 240 to 300 to 300 okay
what's the next profit yeah
i'm sorry what did you do what would the
net profit be on that 240 to 300 because
it sounds like you have a lot of
expenses
yeah the net profit of that would
probably be around 10 to 12 percent
okay so you're only you're making 30 off
of 300 essentially
correct okay i think we need to figure
out how to get a lot of that's a lot of
expenses margins there
right and i think it's because of the
space that we're in maybe um
you know how much we can wholesale costs
have gone up a ton
um due to supply chain issues which has
also taken a beat in on us
um okay so i'm gonna play devil's
advocate real quick ashley so what if
you just got out of the business what if
you woke up tomorrow you're like i'm
done i'm done i'm done are you able to
sell your inventory how are you able to
i is there would you sell the business
to someone else like how what would that
look like to get out of the business so
i've thought about selling the business
to someone else and honestly i
me and my husband just didn't know if
that was possible because of the debt it
has
um i think we do have a syllable
business and that's why i think that i
want i have been holding on to it
because
our plan has to has been to grow it and
sell it right yeah so um
in my eyes they would get all of our
customer list all of our email list our
text list
they would get all of our inventory and
all that so maybe that's a possibility
uh we just haven't we just don't have
the knowledge of that yeah okay well
ninety thousand dollars in business debt
you guys could be completely out in
three years if you just threw everything
or even if you took some of your
husband's income even though it's he's
working for the household expenses throw
some of that and just get your head
above water i don't think you need to
sell the house you don't need to do that
it's not that drastic nope not at all
thanks for the call ashley this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there's a new trend george that is
just it's everywhere it's everywhere
taking over the world it is buy now
pay later consumer debt jumped 52
billion in march the largest
increase on record in california 91 of
consumer loans were made in 2020 were
the buy now pay later loans wow 91 more
than 40 percent of gen z consumers
will have used by now pay later by the
end of the year it's the highest of any
age group
and the and now those debts are going
bad so it is a
it is an interesting thing that is
happening in the world of the buy now
pay later yeah it's the after pays
the clarinet
quad pay zezel i think known as zip now
quad pay and uh we covered this on the
fine print podcast that i did you've
covered it on your show we were just
ahead of the trends and we didn't even
we were like this is bad don't do buy
now pay later now mainstream media is
going hey maybe buy now pay later isn't
helping people
wow
what a shock if you look at their
marketing i was reading another article
so this one's from nymag.com buy now pay
and pay and pay and pay later great
headline sf gate did another one on buy
now pay later and the marketing they
interviewed some of the people at these
companies some of the top executives who
are saying oh buy now pay later it's a
budgeting tool
that's what it is oh how funny yeah
we're not in the lending business we're
helping people with their budget
creating freedom
because we can spread out their payments
month after month after month well we
were just talking about before the show
that that because it's four payments and
it's not five they can avoid regulation
that they can legally avoid regulations
whether it's the fees or the interest
rates and stuff they don't have to abide
uh yeah they don't have to be
transparent with the full cost of the
loan because they don't have to do that
until it's five payments so they get
around it by making it just for just
four payments but it is debt people wow
it is dead yeah this is exploding
especially with influencers on instagram
and tick tock we're seeing influencers
push this because guess what they're
getting a kick back from you using buy
now pay later the retailers are making
money you know they're making forty five
percent more on the average store order
because they have buying a pell later
because it is it's incredible what it
does just to your
your mental state when you are buying
online
and that comes up and says well instead
of a hundred dollars for this order you
could just pay 25. you're like oh just
twenty free up money in your budget that
feels so much better and then you pay
for it the next month and then maybe you
forget the next month and then that's
when the fees kick in and the interest
and all of i mean it's just we're seeing
a lot of people miss payments because
everyone does it with great intentions
but i'll be fine i can pay it and then a
month gets tight and you don't have the
margin you don't have the extra you know
two 200 bucks that you had spread across
all your buy now pay later apps so it
goes on to say buy now pay later seduce
the generation with a great pitch the
firms position themselves as a
financially responsible alternative to
credit because per afterpay's former
executive director young people quote
don't want to be on credit if the first
rule of marketing is give people what
they want a corollary is give them what
they don't want just call it something
else so by now later they're trying to
act like no no we're not like credit
cards we're like not even really debt
we're just trying to help you spread
your payments out that's all it is but
the truth is they're just as bad if not
more predatory than any other lender any
other credit card company out there
that's out there because it is it's debt
and if you've listened to the show for
more than two minutes you know
this idea of becoming debt free having
no debt no payments does something not
only financially in your life and
mathematically but it does something
spiritually for your mental health you
sleep better at night you make different
decisions in life you maybe even could
switch jobs i mean there's so much
freedom and options and margin that
comes with living below your means and
getting out of debt and so one of the
best tools that we have that helps
people walk through how to manage their
money
fully including getting out of debt is
financial peace university so if you've
taken financial peace university before
which over 10
million people have you know that it's
life-changing but it's hard to watch
other people struggle you know when
you've gone through this journey and you
see other people and they're just me i
mean they're living paychecks to
paycheck they're not changing their
habits they're continuing to live in the
cycle it is so difficult so
now we have the opportunity to help them
change their family tree and you out
there who have gone through financial
business university have that ability to
to be able to give them a ramsay plus
gift card because it bundles everything
they need to win with money and just one
gift so the gift card includes financial
peace university a year of premium the
premium version of every dollar which is
the best budgeting app obsessed tracked
my transactions this morning
love it and now you also have the
unlimited group coaching from our own
financial coaches they're amazing uh
absolutely incredible and you could pay
for all of these separately but it cost
over five hundred dollars uh but now
just through the month of may only you
can get a ramsay plus gift card for just
99
and this summer that's legit make sure
to share the hope that
maybe you've discovered by giving
someone a ramsay plus gift card so just
visit ramseysolutions.com
gift that's ramsay solutions dot com
slash gift all right up next is joseph
from little rock arkansas hey joseph
welcome to the show
hi how are y'all we're doing great how
can we help
bottom line we have a six month old baby
and basically um
just just want to know how to plan for
the future i mean the world is crazy
my job i don't know how long the supply
would keep up and we could hit a hiccup
in my job to where you know
can't get the materials you can't work
so
i'm just trying to figure out the best
way to prepare for that long term okay
so so you guys are debt-free
uh do you guys have money saved in the
bank
uh yes how much do you have is it
three we recommend that the three to six
months of expenses
uh we have about 28 000. okay so what is
that what is that for you guys like if
if you're so say your job stopped
immediately how many months
would you guys have to that you'd be
okay
we can live on 1500 a month
okay and you have how much savings um
uh 28 000. oh wow you got plenty it's a
fully funded emergency fund for you guys
i mean you're looking at nine grand and
you've got 28.
yeah so you got plenty there so what are
you worried about
losing your job
no no not that
my dad's my dad has a bunch of rental
property
and you know that that's great but
there's also a lot of overhead in rental
property there's you know there's
management problems then there's also
you know they're just a lot of overhead
and he's big into rental property rental
property but right now you can't buy
rental property it's ridiculous so other
than that you know i just the best way
to plan
besides just rental property
so are you trying to plan for the future
are you planning for the apocalypse i
can't tell sure
um the future okay so if you're just
looking at the future you're 21 you've
got your whole life ahead of you you've
got this six month old
are you just wanting to invest to make
sure that you're able to retire when you
want to
yes okay are you guys investing anything
right now
no we're not you're not okay so that's
the first thing i would do joseph is i
would press play
on your investing strategy which would
be putting 15 of your household income
into retirement every year so whether
that's um you know roth ira is a great
option does your company offer a 401k
uh no it's family business it's a
failing business okay so yeah so i would
just i would talk to a smart fester pro
and look to see okay here are my options
um to put some money away and it could
be you know through a retirement vehicle
is ideal is that 15 and then above that
if you guys still have margin you're
okay i want to i want to do something
then yeah above that is when you look at
um you know paying off your current
house if it's not paid off and then also
you know whether it's investing in the
market and good mutual funds if it is
buying a rental property which could be
you know four years down the road
because usually when you buy an
investment property the way
we go about it and i know for sure dave
it's it's that you make your money on
the sale so it would be a situation
where it's
something yes where you get a great deal
and you pay cash for it so joseph do you
have a mortgage
no okay so you're renting right now
no we own it
you own it oh you own it free and clear
how much you guys make a year yeah
um
the average week is around three to five
thousand but there's some weeks we're in
the roof in business so you know we
can't roof all year so there's some
business where we may go you know
several weeks without working at all
well you got no payments in the world
and uh you're making 60 grand invest 15
do the roth ira beyond that you might
look at a brokerage account but dude
you're going to build wealth you're 21.
yeah relax breathe slow and great wins
the race you're doing great joseph doing
great
well that wraps up this hour of at the
ramsay show thanks to austin kelly will
zach and andrew in the booth thank you
george for hosting and we'll be back
america
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your
money so it's a free call anywhere in
the country at
825-5225 and i am rachel cruz co-hosting
today with ramsey personality george
hamill
all right we're gonna go right to the
phones this hour and maria in lexington
kentucky is up next hey maria welcome to
the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
so my question um that i have is
um
we are debt free
my husband and i and um we have about 70
000 left on our mortgage that's our only
um sort of debt um we already have our
six six month emergency fund
um and i have been working a lot the
last year and a half um
to we have like about
fifty three thousand dollars um
saved up in like a little extra funds
um that we don't exactly
know what to do with um
we also have twenty thousand dollars um
for our next car fund we have older cars
um one is 20 years old the other one's
13 years old and so we've just been kind
of putting money away for those um
so my question is um do we take our
extra money that we have which is
basically 73 000
between the car and the extra extra
and do we
throw it at the house do we
um throw part of it at the house um a
part of me would love to be completely
debt-free
from the house and everything
or do we put it towards like retirement
do we we have um three kids that are
ages four five and eight
do we like put some towards extra
college fund
we just don't really know what to do
with our money right now how much do you
guys make a year maria combined
um combined we are
around 110 usually last year we made
160. oh wow okay
that's great so worth a lot of extra are
you guys funding retirement now
yes we are putting uh
probably about 20
away for retirement okay and have you
guys started any college funds for the
kids
yes we do have college funds um going
that we started when they were each born
okay we um we put some tours out every
month um but didn't know if like we
should put like a chunk um towards it
more towards it
you guys are doing great maria doing
amazing
um you know your car you're gonna have
to replace those soon um yeah and so for
me that would be because i mean you guys
are on baby steps classic four five and
six and you're doing everything you're
funding actually a little bit more into
retirement than you need to be you could
even pull back some of that to that 15
which would free up even more cash to
throw at the house uh your kids college
funds are funded and i would just double
check maybe with your smart investor pro
or your investment professional who
you're working with just to make sure
that's that those are on track uh
looking at inflation and tuition rates
and kind of where how that money's going
to grow and just double check that
and then um and then what's left there
yeah is the mortgage so i think that
there is a chunk of this
um of that 53 000 that you could
definitely throw towards the mortgage
but also again on this step we talk
about the intensity
the gazelle intensity if you will uh is
baby steps one through three now we say
you can take your foot off the gas like
you guys are okay you're good you can
breathe you can take vacation
uh like we say you can replace cars or
redo that kitchen you've wanted to do
whatever it is uh if there's something
in your mind that you really want to do
we're not gonna be mad if you use some
of that money for that but if you guys
if everything else is covered
man the thought of throwing
50 000 something very 10 at that
mortgage and be like man we only got 20
000 i'm a nerd and so i'm probably
throwing it all at the house and dialing
even the car even the car even the car
here's my thing you're going to be able
to save up for a new car real quick when
you don't have a mortgage payment yeah
making one time yeah right and so i i'm
not mad if you hold off and leave that
car fun because i don't know what the
shape of your cars are in but if i'm
going i could drive this thing for six
more months and so what i did personally
rachel is i dangled the upgrading car in
front of me as we pay it off the house
so that i'm not going to upgrade the car
until we pay off the house once the
house is paid off then i'll save up and
get the car i really want and we were
able to do that really fast without a
mortgage payment so i think either way
you're going to be fine if you save this
car fund put the 53 towards the mortgage
you're left with a twenty thousand
dollar mortgage that's gone within the
next what seven months no you only have
a seventy thousand dollar mortgage so
that's a seventy three thousand dollar
mortgage yeah seventy yeah yeah and you
have 73 total saved you have 53. so you
could pay off the house today if you
wanted to which leaves you with no car
yeah correct yeah which is what you
would do which is what i personally
would do because i don't mind driving a
beater and you'll have the money to cash
flow a repair if you need to and within
a few months you'll we back up to 20
000. maria what's your what's your
husband's take what's what's his
thoughts
well you know it's funny because we um
had um we were completely debt-free
morgan's in all um and then we moved
right before the pandemic um and so he
was gazelle intense to pay off the house
our original house
and then um i feel like i am more
gazelle intense to just get rid of it
this time and so um he is more kind of
put the brakes on and enjoy
um
not feeling like we're you know
living on rice and beans and
having a little bit more are you guys
living on rice and beans right now do
you feel like that no we're really not
we're really not um but
i
um
i go in spurts of um okay we're this is
like no spend march uh let's like see
how much we can save up and to pay off
the house yeah so yeah you guys sound a
lot like me and my wife and that's just
how we were we were intense about it
because we just felt like it and we just
have that drive because there's a part
of you that you're like
what if you guys what if you did what if
you just wrote a check paid off paid off
the house does that excite you to like
write a check today and pay off the
house
100
yes that excites me and it's not even my
house i know i know i just like that how
are the cars how are the cars is it
gonna die is one of the cars gonna die
tomorrow
um
there is one that could potentially die
tomorrow yes the 20 year old one
that's pretty one year old one is in
good shape but you guys make great money
so i'm like even if you kept
10 000 in the car fund for the one car
that might try tomorrow split the
difference throw everything else the
next
next pay period or two paychecks throw
it at the mortgage
uh yeah and you guys could be you you
could be completely debt free in three
months
uh doing that and then at the club i'm
saying either way within a few months
you have a paid for house and you can
upgrade in car
there's not a right or wrong here it's
kind of just how intense you want to be
george campbell and say
no one wants to be
everyone wants to be george campbell not
if you're a horse lover
it's for another day but maria you're
doing great i'm proud of you guys uh
this is an inspiring call to hear
someone struggle with a pile of
cash know what's your gut maria what's
your gut
um my gut is to pay off the house do it
maria finally answer i think you settled
it i think you know it i think you do it
and this is who wants to be a
millionaire
final answer it's all yours the next
paycheck there's no payments coming out
of it that feels good that filter the
first one that comes through is
life-changing that's pretty great maria
thanks for the call
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
welcome back america to the ramsey show
it's a free call anywhere in the country
triple eight eight two five five two two
five up next is cats in orlando hey kat
welcome to the show hi thanks guys
thanks for taking my call absolutely how
can we help
well i am looking at a second relocation
for a promotion in two years
and um
the relocation package that i have
through my work um is very healthy
i don't want to leave the house that i'm
in i love the house that i'm in but i
feel like i would be leaving money on
the table because they are covering all
of the fees and whatnot for the
transaction and then they actually do
the gross up at the end of the year so
there's really no tax
consequences for me
but i just don't know if i i've been
fortunate enough that i've i've uh built
even in just a year between the market
and i've been doing a principal
curtailment every month i've you know
got a decent amount of equity i guess my
question is is do i
now try and like downsize and maximize
my down payment and capitalize on that
that you know equity or
do i hold on to the house i mean i don't
want to hold on to the house i want to
but i don't want to because i don't want
to have to worry about it while i'm out
of state somewhere else and then
renting possibly so
i just don't know if my thinking is
correct that
you know given the fact that they're
covering
so much of the
the financial burden of a move
i.e real estate fees and transactions
and whatnot
so you're still working for the same
company and they're relocating you to a
different city different office correct
yeah different different stages is this
in two years is that what you said
yeah okay so what's making you worry now
what's what's the what's the urgency are
you saying this is your second
relocation in two years so you've just
moved around a lot
yeah yeah and it took me forever to find
the house that i'm in and i really like
it and then looking at
you know i'm moving from florida to to
south carolina and the houses there are
a lot different uh
it's going to be hard to find something
that i really like when you move to
south carolina in two years will you be
moving again in two more years
um no well i would be looking at
relocating to south carolina in about 30
days um but in south carolina i'd
probably only be there about three years
oh i hear you imagine i would rent if
you're anywhere less than five years
i don't think it's worth especially
where the market is right now i'm like
you're gonna be buying high
who knows what's gonna be happening in
the next two years if i were you i'd
find a great place and i would rent
since you're going to be gone in three
years
but then what am i am i leaving money on
the table though because they're paying
for the
all of the
like the real estate fees and all that
kind of stuff they're covering they're
paying all of that so paying your
closing costs if you sell your current
home right
yeah and if you buy a new one are they
covering those closing costs too
yeah they pay uh like up to i think like
ten thousand of the closing costs on the
new home
because you could buy it because think
about okay here's worst case scenario i
mean i'm never this person but i want to
be this person cat what if you find a
house in south carolina and you're like
okay i'm going to bid and you go against
someone you pay over asking because
that's what so many places are doing
right now that 10 000 is going to look
like so small compared to what you could
be overpaying for a house right now so
in my head that's great and generous
they're doing that see if they'll pay
for all of your moving costs and see if
they'll pay first month's rent you know
transfer the same amount of money they
would have paid yeah
well yeah so yeah so i would get like a
lump sum like a modest lump sum let's
say five to six thousand dollars but
then on top of that
obviously they pay the labor move part
they move all the furniture they pack
with all the furniture but they also
cover
all of the transaction fees associated
with buying and selling on this so you
wouldn't get it
you would get it on the sale of your
house if you sold your house in florida
but you just wouldn't get on the buying
end if you just rent i for the hassle of
it even though i know it sounds like
you're leaving money on table but it's
not that much money in comparison of
what a mortgage is going to be
yeah i mean the mortgage the the
i mean
i guess it's six and one half dozen
dozen of the other then i guess my
question is is that what do i what do
you recommend i do with that you know
130 000 that i'm going to get from the
sale of this house
you know should i
just invest it all i guess or like yeah
do you have any other do you have debt
cat at all consumer debt
uh no no consumer debt well i have a car
note which to be honest i should
probably just pay off i'm just a little
thank you for being honest
how much how much do you own your how
much do you own your car
about ten thousand okay okay so
some of that forty thousand forty
thousand liquid oh wow well just pay off
the car today yeah pay off the car today
and then the rest of the money um yeah i
mean i would take some of it and look
into um investing in just a good growth
stock mutual fund because you're not
going to lose money for a few years then
pardon me you won't touch this money for
a few years at least
well probably not until i get moved you
know until i relocate again okay i would
imagine if it's three plus years and
you're debt-free i think it's fine in
the market if you're willing to ride the
wave and you don't need it urgently
so do you think i should sell the house
in florida then or do you think i would
yes i would sell it you don't want to be
a long distance landlord
no no and then yeah but everything you
were saying though of how excited you
were that they were going to pay all the
closing everything yeah for the sale too
so you get to take advantage of that
which is a gift so take advantage of
that sell the home yes get some money in
the bank and and invest some of that for
sure um because here's the deal in three
years yeah go ahead
i was just gonna say so i did see like a
duplex that was available for purchase
in south carolina i haven't really dug
into it but
what about if i purchased like a duplex
where i could rent out you know and
create maybe some cash flow on the one
side and live in the other side and
yeah and you probably could get that for
around one third what was the price on
that do you know
uh it was
four or four something i think okay so i
would
make better about what like a 35 down
payment on it do you want to live there
or is it just like a money-making scheme
it would be to like generate revenue
yeah i think you're fine financially i
don't think you need to rent out i mean
if i were you are you single married
yeah no single okay i would go i mean i
if i were you i would go find an awesome
condo or duplex or um you know townhouse
and a really fun part of the city you're
gonna be in
and just enjoy it and don't worry about
owning everything right now because
again you're gonna be there for three
years you're gonna be leaving anyways i
would just enjoy i think take a deep
breath you're doing great how much do
you make a year
uh with this new promotion the number we
haven't got to the numbers uh final yet
i'm thinking probably about between one
and 105. heck yeah yeah
fine don't get a roommate don't i if if
i were you i don't know am i sounding
lazy
just go and enjoy rachel is a free
spirit spender you've worked hard cat
you're gonna have no debt because you're
gonna pay off your car today with your
40 000 you have in the bank
sell your house in florida do the move
see if they'll pay for any of the other
you know maybe one month's rent or two
months rent
of the new place
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i am
rachel cruz hosting this hour with
george camel and up next we have
christopher in birmingham
hey christopher welcome to the show
hey guys thank y'all for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
um so a bit of a of a long story is that
as much of a success story as the last
couple of calls no it's okay um
but um i'm a 26 year old father i have a
one-year-old
and my son is due in two weeks oh
congratulations
thank you thank you very much i'm
extremely excited
um
but anyways we're we're struggling
pretty pretty hard financially i've
tried to do
as much as i know how to do as far as
making an
excel spreadsheet you know budget and
trying to see make sure where everything
goes and make sure everything's
allocated yeah where it should go and
i just i always seem to come up to come
up short
we had
from where we bought our house in august
we had a consolidation loan to try to
make sure that we could get everything
into one thing
and then um and then after the baby was
born life just kind of happened all at
once and then
the consolidation loan just became too
much
so i ended up having to sell my prized
possession which was my truck um that i
had built from the ground up basically
sold it and paid off the consolidation
loan and a little bit of of outstanding
debt and
i've still got some credit card debt
left
but for some reason it just seems like
every every month every week that i'm
doing the spreadsheet
you know i'm coming up with next to
nothing extra to try to snowball
on these credit cards and much less put
back into savings um
and it's just it's just a real it's
overwhelming a real gameboy every month
and it's extremely overwhelming
um
my dad
bought dave's book and
you know he's been trying to help me
through it and we're just you know i
don't know where else to turn other than
just kind of go with my hat in my hand
and
and ask for help oh well christopher
you're doing a great job let me just say
that it's a lot right now i mean how old
are you
guys uh i'm 26 my wife is 29. i'm just i
want to get a handle on it before yeah
before it gets out of control and we
want to have you know the ability to
we want to have the ability to move back
home and enjoy life and you know do
things for our kids
well that we never would expect that we
could do absolutely and you will be able
to and that's the great thing is that
first
motivation point is your why and that
you're sick and tired of being sick and
tired this is the breaking point this is
where people get where they're like all
right i am willing to do whatever it
takes
to turn this around so christopher how
much do you guys make a year
um i i don't know the math on that 100 i
know i make um
our net
every month is roughly 35 to 38. she's a
manager in retail okay so her hours kind
of fluctuate a little bit and they're
fluctuating a lot especially with the
late stage of her pregnancy and doctor's
appointments and stuff like that but my
i'm on salary so i make
uh i make right at 2 400 a month by
myself take home pays about 45 grand a
year
somewhere around there
45 okay so christopher i'll just give
you just the stats that the average
household income dual income was 65 last
year so you guys are living below
average when it comes to just a combined
household income
what kind of job what kind of work do
you do
i'm an athletic trainer i work in sports
medicine okay cool
at a local
gym or high school or i work for a local
it's a um i work for a physical therapy
company
but they outsource the us athletic
trainers to be
a full-time care at the like local high
schools or colleges i work at a local
high school to provide healthcare for
the kids okay
um and what what's your work how many
hours a week are you working
i'm working
right around
it fluctuates during football season i'm
working right at 60 hours a week and
then during
not football season i'm probably right
around 25
to 35. okay
how much debt do you guys have currently
um we have a little over 12. okay
do you think once you got out of debt
that you would find that margin
are these payments killing that margin
because you said you're doing the budget
but there's nothing left at the end of
the month is that because it's going
back out to payments on the debt yeah
are there other issues everything's
going out the is going up the payments
like
it's going out towards is your mortgage
too high credit cards
no my mortgage is fine i have i'm able
to make the mortgage every month what's
the mortgage what percentage of your
budget is your mortgage
uh percentage uh what are you guys
paying for your mortgage yeah well yeah
we'll pay it we're paying 9.77 for okay
so that's reasonable considering your
take-home pay that's not the problem i'm
just looking to see where the problems
are at because when you do the budget
there's more
there's just a lot of money like little
payments and stuff going out all over
the place with i've got three credit
card payments we've got daycare that
comes out every
every week it's 180 a week for daycare
and then we've got hospital bills from
where my last one was born and we're
going to end up racking up more from
this new one
okay and this all adds up to 12k all of
your debt credit cards medical bills
or is there more
yeah other that's that's everything
other than my wife's car payment
oh what's the car loan
uh the car loan i think she's down to
9 500.
okay
left on it but the payment is uh the
payment is 294.
and that's on top of the 12.
yeah so we're looking more like 22 000
in consumer debt
yeah
now i'm starting to get a real picture
of where the struggle's coming from
yeah well uh
there's a few things you can do
obviously we need to get rid of this
debt and having those payments freed up
is going to help you guys immensely but
the other thing you need to do i would
get on every dollar instead of the
spreadsheet and see if that helps you
because we'll gift you the premium
version that's inside of ramsey plus
along with financial peace and so you
guys can track it it'll be connected to
your bank and you need to really stare
at every penny going out going where
could we cut where could we cut how do
we bring more money in that's how you're
going to create that margin to
do the debt snowball and to christopher
i would say upping your income so really
the two ways that you're going to see
movement to the most
is cutting the budget but there may not
be a ton there could be some to cut for
sure but there may not be a ton just
seeing what you guys make a month
knowing all of your expenses from
daycare food everything so but the the
other end of the of the spectrum is your
income
and that's what i would wonder is hey
you got i mean you said during you know
during certain times of the year you're
working crazy hours versus it goes down
when it's not when you're not in season
and so it's either
looking at christopher which could be
very uncomfortable for you but just like
hey what's a totally different job
because that what people are paying
right now
for workers and for wages is is is it's
insane it's insane and so what what
would it look like to go to a completely
different industry
just to get your head above water even
if it's something that you don't really
want to do you don't love it but they're
paying
50 grand a year yeah um
hospitality retail i mean they're paying
15. because 45 000 is household incomes
that includes your wife's which means
you're making even less than that so you
could be you know i'm not sure what
you're making but it could be around 35
000
30 000 so um i just think you could you
could be making more
and again this is not a forever move but
there is these extreme measures that you
guys are gonna have to take because
you're kind of in an extreme situation
you guys have
have a lot of debt again your shovel's
not huge
um with your income and so there's
something to be said about man what if
we just turn the tables and i know you
have a new baby coming so maybe you wait
until that
until mom and baby and everyone is good
and then maybe you just make a leap and
say hey for 18 24 months
we're just gonna go crazy and we're
gonna cut the budget we're gonna do
every dollar and stick to it i'm gonna
see what extra job i can either take on
or maybe even move industries completely
and just say man i'm gonna just take a
higher paying job for now
um just to get some traction and then
you could look up you know in eight 24
months and be like okay we can breathe
again this feels good and then i can go
back and do what i love um when it comes
to this but maybe there's something even
within your skill set
a different position that you could do
but that income i would look to see
getting that up that's what's going to
help you get your head above water
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scripture of the day is the fruit of the
spirit is love
joy peace patience kindness goodness
faithfulness gentleness and self-control
galatians 5 22 3.
as i grow older i pay less
less attention to what men say i just
watch what they do
andrew carnegie
so it's been proven over and over again
that you can crush your financial your
personal your professional goals so
whether you want to pay off debt
land that dream job or build better
relationships you really can make it
happen and so we're putting our number
one best-selling books and tools
in the ramsey 10
sale to give to you the proven plan of
how to knock out those goals so if you
have money goals you're trying to hit or
learn how to get out of debt and build
wealth there's the total money makeover
or know yourself know your money for
just ten dollars
as you're making your summer plans have
meaningful actually real deep
conversations with people you care about
so a great tool for that is questions
for humans couples edition or friends
edition
or if you have a high school grad and
you want them
you want to give them a gift that will
help them escape the traps of student
loans make sure to pick up the graduate
survival guide or our brand new high
school gift pack so listen there's
something for everyone and we know it
ten bucks
doesn't get you much anymore so
during the sale make sure to check it
out ten dollars actually has a lot of
value at ramsey's solution didn't hit us
here at ramsey it's still the 10 sales
still not the 11 sale no and it's going
to be over so soon you guys so make sure
you plan today to go to
ramseysolutions.com
everything is up to
percent off that's insane so make sure
to hit that up before the sale ends
all right we're gonna be going to joe in
washington dc hey joe welcome to the
show
hey y'all thanks for taking the call
excited to talk to you today absolutely
how can we help
uh so i feel like i'm jumping on the
bandwagon here and uh talking more real
estate with y'all i love it the
situation is that i've got an
opportunity to buy a triplex to where
i'm moving up in new york next month i'm
moving for work
and
um let's say you know the worst case
scenario is it's just me in the building
right at that point it would be about 40
of my take-home pay to cover the whole
mortgage with one tenant in there would
be about 20 and with two tenants in
there including me i could live for free
amazing i have no other debt and i make
about 120 a year and i just i've been
looking around
i haven't really been able to see what
uh what the ramsey family insight is
into uh house hacking as the real estate
community calls it yeah house hacking
yeah we've got some of these calls
before usually they're uh how old are
you joe
i'm 32. okay usually it's younger guys
guys in their early 20s they've got no
money to their name they've got a pile
of debt and they're calling us going hey
should i do this house hacking thing i
saw it on tick tock and i can make a
bunch of money your situation's a little
bit different
yeah how much money do you have to put
down on it
um it's a let's give me a federal loan
so i'll be going
you know real low five percent i could
put down
um you know 10 15 uh but that would be
that most of the reserves i would have
for you know maintaining the house and
you know catastrophe and is the numbers
you ran is that on a 30-year fixed rate
it is yeah okay
well that changes my answer slightly
i'm i'm not a fan of a 30-year
versus a 15. do you have any other debt
joe
do you have any debt no i have no no
debt and i've got about you know
75 in in non-retirement accounts and
about 200 and their time right now okay
and will you be in new york for the long
term like do you see for the
foreseeable future that's where you'll
be
uh you know the current contract is
three years so we'll oh okay that
happens in three years
oh man we just had a call so similar to
this um in the last segment
yeah i don't know i i just for me
getting into something
that
again the math you could make it work
here but i think there's just hassle and
buying something especially when it
comes to real estate in new york i'm
like oh
um
i don't know since you're there short
term
i don't know if i would fool with it but
george may have my personal i just
personally wouldn't do it are you is
your life going to be over if you'd make
this move no it's just not what i would
do it's not uh the ramsay plan is we do
50 or 15 year fixed rate have a good
healthy down payment and have the
payment be no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay now you're seeing the
upside of well if i get these renters in
here that are on time that are reliable
that don't cause a lot of issues and
there's zero maintenance to do i'll be
okay
but when i look at it i also see a whole
bunch of risk involved
and i'm never going to steer someone
towards a 30-year fixed rate because joe
you're 32 you have a long full life
ahead of you i don't want you to be tied
down with a mortgage and i know people
say well rachel they're paying they're
paying the mortgage for me it's free
nothing in life is free when it comes to
real estate yeah there's always going to
be uh maintenance repairs you you've got
the mortgage property taxes insurance
you name it extra liability with these
tenants so if you can swing it on a
15-year fixed rate and you had the same
numbers i'd go okay i feel a lot better
about that if you had a healthy down
payment i'd go i feel better about that
but at the numbers you you gave me it
makes me uncomfortable you're just right
on that line joe a little bit of like oh
i could go it could go south really
quick and you're gonna regret doing it
would you cash out the 75 non-retirement
to do it
i don't think so because then you know
i'm riding strictly on
uh just on my monthly and coming on my
on my w-2 so 75 is what you're seeing
here
you're saying the 75 is your reserves
yes but it's currently invested
it's in you know it's in mutual funds
just like regular uh you know highly
liquid mutual funds yeah i mean if you
cashed it out and that became your down
payment you could do a 15 year i'd feel
a lot more like there's a lot more
breathing room for you
so that's what i would do personally
again we treat calls what we would do if
i woke up in your shoes and that's what
i would personally do yep there's just a
lot of factors and i know it sounds
exciting and kind of like ooh cool okay
i could get this and this and this and
this and it would work so well and could
it work absolutely it could but also it
could go downhill real quick so
if you were to do it it would be on a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage
uh yeah with no more um or with a bigger
down payment so i would put down yeah 10
to 15 percent there and then you got to
just be real sure that you'd get them
that you'd get roommates in there but
hopefully that would lower the
percentage of which you would your
mortgage of what you would pay but all
all of the math needs to work really
well
for us to feel good about it or you're
just dealing with a lot of hassle and
you could be a little bit hassle free
all right up next is fred from el paso
hey fred welcome to the show
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call i appreciate the time absolutely
how can we help
yes so my question is
my wife has some current student loans
they're trying to pay off um that's the
only that we have we would like to know
if it's a smart move to go and refinance
those under my name because my wife is a
homemaker so she's right now with with
our baby so i just want to make sure um
if it's my move or if it's not
what would the benefit be of refinancing
the loans into your name
probably just the interest rate i mean
that would be the only benefit but i'm
not sure if
we have one at seven percent another one
at eight percent she's got like 10
different loans so again it's just i
don't know what would be the best move
now are you talking about consolidation
or refinancing
either one honestly i haven't thought
about either option so
just kind of some guidance there okay
well i would not do consolidation
because you're just moving things around
and paying for it but you can look into
refinancing there's a company that we've
recommended in the past splash financial
and if you can do it and there's no fee
to you so it's completely free to
refinance and you can keep a fixed rate
or get to a fixed rate i assume they're
on a fixed rate and you can lower the
interest rate then i feel good about it
now if they're going to sign you up for
a longer repayment period to do it not a
good idea yeah and there's no benefit
even fred for you to
um
to refinance under your name versus hers
you could just keep it under hers now
she doesn't have an income i don't know
how you know
which i think is part of his question if
you're a homemaker i would contact
splash financial and see what they can
do and if they can give you a lower rate
and keep your repayment period and keep
it fixed yeah then i feel good about
that yeah and debt consolidation the
only type of debt we say that is okay is
student loans because you're tempted
because a lot of people use that
consolidation thread to move move the
debt around like um like george just
said and it feels good because it's like
oh i'm doing something when you're
really not doing something but if you
can consolidate all those get a lower
rate even then together you could do
that it's not terrible but keeping them
separate is great because you can pay
off that smallest one first and keep
that momentum going that's snowball
magic yeah so definitely look into the
refinancing um just to see if you can
get a lower interest rate but great
question thanks fred
all right this put
this hour of the ramsay show in the
books i never said that line but i like
it thanks to austin kelly will and zach
for being great there behind the booth
george fantastic show
so great thanks for co-hosting thank you
america for listening this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
debt ramseysolutions.com screen we'd
love for you to come to nashville and
tell dave your story that's ramsey
solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you